[Music]
as a production designer I'm responsible
for creating the world that the
narrative takes place in so my job is to
not design the place so much as to try
to find a way that as you move through
it you become the main character by the
end of this experience when they didn't
do much green in this movie as you can
imagine by technical aspect very
important what kind of Earth would give
the actors some comfort even to
especially in this scene to be on top of
it because of the Earth in general was
very full of clay very sticky actually
very dangerous keep it really real and
relatable for people because whether
it's designing a creature or figuring
out the technical dressing for a
laboratory or designing a vehicle I
always try to bring a sense of
authenticity to the sets so I always say
we've got to back it up with that and we
look into the science behind the set
getting way more more into Navi design
and we see how the mechanina draw
inspiration from the sea it's out in the
oceans we connect it with the fractal
Coral shapes and all the sinuous shapes
and the roots of the spirit tree
and then the contrast to what happened
when the sound Technologies came in
tapping into like the early prototypes
of what the camera boxes look like what
the microphones look like how that
quickly developed so even as we progress
in those sets in the sound era that
they're developing and changing what was
so awesome about Babylon was it was kind
of like a throwback to the movies I grew
up watching you know for me I love the
history of movies history of Cinema it
was awesome to be part of telling that
story
[Music]
baz thought it was important to show a
little window into a world that nobody
knew I think that's the key a lot of the
design in the film we were making things
from history and we had a lot of
reference we also have the audience
understand how it felt to be in that
room or how it felt to be in that place
what I think we're trying to do here is
to never lose the illusion that you're
somewhere in a cinematic world
[Music]